thank you
[Music]
welcome back to a very special episode
of the careful boys we are currently
I like that charge nailed it Ryan
charged up man today we are talking
about
the biggest thing you lied to your
parents about
where do I stop me
that's a lot okay the biggest biggest
[__] lie and it's okay if you've come
clean since then or is it only stuff
that is maintained to maintain it I need
to reveal it right now till this day oh
they know everything do they but at the
time there was a lie time I lied about
everything and then now they know
everything but first thing would
probably be about uh there was this kid
that I was kind of pranking and [__]
around with and he had this
so he had this rulers [__] around
give your lunch money
remember the ruler with a calculator at
the end of course
right oh [__] nerd right I've never
seen it never seen it so yeah there's a
it's like a ruler at the end are you
human
button you can press for like
calculating and [__] it's like those
calculator watches but on a ruler cool
yeah a ruler that needs batteries I
thought it was [__] hilarious right
so I don't know he was one of the guys
that we were always like [__] with so
then when he wasn't looking I grabbed it
and then I went behind like the
bookshelves and I threw it under there
and then he said that like one of my
friends stole it became this whole like
whodunit mystery oh right and then I
told my parents like I didn't [__] do
[__] whatever and then you know when
you're a kid you [__] feel guilty and
then you want to be like you know what I
think I know where it is but
you know what I don't know and then the
teacher would just be like really show
me where it is and then I go I think I
saw so and so play with it and so and so
play with it and then they flew it flew
in the air because they were fighting
they were like doing a tug of war and
then it flew it's always the most
outlandish warm feeling it's just really
warm right here I think it was behind
why do you care so much you're weirdo
Joe's the guy who like who there's a
murder and Joe's lawyering around he's
like oh you guys got a big murder I got
any suspects yet
bro I [__] the funniest part though
is like yeah they egged me on or like I
did it right but I [__] took down
like seven people with me because I was
like yeah this person was fighting with
this person and this person was that and
then this dude we all ratted on each
other we [__] I thought you're not a
rep hey I learned my lesson man I beat
myself up at in third grade okay or
fourth grade whatever it was but I think
that was the beginning of like oh [__]
like I just straight up Cold Stone Face
lied to my parents and at the very end
obviously they knew you know come on
dude like I knew exactly where the
[__] ruler was you know come on dude
I think my my biggest slide that I could
think of
was junior year in high school
um
because I because I think till this day
I don't know if my mom knows the truth
but I don't I don't have any problem
telling her but when I got kicked out it
was at the military school and it was me
and like 11 other dudes all getting
kicked out because through their
surveillance camera they saw like all of
us running at like 4am to go to 7-Eleven
because we're all rolling on E and we
all thought it would be great to get
orange juice and [__] and it get higher
because you know you know orange juice
when you're on is very delicious smoke
some new parts oh the Menthol through
the lungs oh it feels so good so we're
running we got caught in the morning
because the [__] uh the commandant
aka the principal was driving to school
that early for some reason you see all
these kids just running off so they're
like he was like literally driving he
goes uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh [__]
so they gathered us you're the worst and
then and then they found out that uh
this whole our little crew has been the
crew that's been supplying ecstasy
through the whole school so they um it's
a serious crime so they ended up
expelling us right and then my mom has
nothing good my mom has never
heard of me even dabbling with drugs or
anything like that whoa I've got the
phone call she was like what part drugs
impossible impossible and so you look me
like straight in the eyes like you
didn't sell any drugs I'm like no way
what the [__] I'm like it's [__]
white people are tripping and then so
he's white like another tripping I don't
know they're putting it on me I don't
know why they probably just want to like
they they'll throw us out there they
frame me Mom
and then she was like she's like no no
no look I know I know you did it I'm
like no no just dude I [__] do piss
test because I was just trying to like
you know you're trying to like get more
and more ballsy to see if they'll call
your bluff yeah right right and then so
she's like oh okay my son's down to do a
piss test oh okay okay yeah yeah so we
ended I end up getting expelled I went
home and then my mom's like you know
what I think we need to get that piss
test I'm like yeah do a [__] go right
now you wanna go piss uncle right now
I'm ready to piss right now and then she
ends up setting up an appointment we go
to uh our family doctor and then when
I'm sitting in the waiting room I'm like
I found the dog the family doctor could
[__] do piss tests I thought they
just get penicillin or some [__] and
then so I was like I can't believe we're
going through with this [__] and then
the doctor was like yeah we don't
usually do this but uh we can I do um I
have a lab that I can send repeat out to
so like every like little you're like
holy every inch of the way I'm like
there's there's got to be a way out of
there just gonna be a way out of there
zombie way out of this and then finally
um it was my turn to pee in the cup and
uh this when I was like oh [__] okay
this is tight because I thought they're
gonna watch me pee but because it's a
family doctor they're not really a drug
testing place they're like just go to
the bathroom and then yeah you just do
it so I peed literally like two drops
and I filled the rest up with just warm
water because I was like at least
they'll feel warm yeah and then and then
if I have ecstasy or whatever the [__] I
have it'd be diluted it'd be super
diluted and you're so dehydrated two
drops is like food coloring what if
they're like we found traces of probably
the weakest e ever
the toilet and it was extremely strong
so they took that to the lab they ran
they didn't say it came back as water it
came back and then they're like there
were like uh traces Trace Amounts of
amphetamines whatever whatever but it's
all it's all within the normal normal
amounts that's in your regular drinking
water a normal method my mom got the got
the lab envelope and I remember it's
being on the uh our washing machine in
the garage where like my mom's like it's
here and I want to open it with you and
I was like oh [__] oh [__] my Palms were
[__] like all cold and [__] I'm
trying to play cool I'm like I'm like
yeah let's open it together I already
know what's gonna be on there
they opened it and then it was all under
the normal levels and I'm like see I
[__] told you that's when you dunk as
hard as you can I should get a pizza
party this has been [__] up an
innocent man again charged with a crime
she frames it and I was like holy [__] I
can't believe that actually works did it
again this is a hot freaking story bro
this is a good story all the way to the
end and it was like oh my God oh my God
oh what the [__] is actually working
holy [__]
it's like a family practice they're not
testing criminals so they have to
probably Outsource to Outsource and
Outsource and like oh yeah okay I have a
friend that's a lab that'll run step of
the way they care even less yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so that was until
this day I don't know my mom knows okay
I'll do one of those to this day I don't
know if my mom knows
uh I remember going to a bookstore my
mama's probably like the tender age of
like 12 or 11. and I remember this was
like around the time when like you know
all the kids at school were talking
about sex and [__] like that but then
like I
I got busted because I was I was like my
mom's like you know looking around the
[__] Oprah book club section
and then I took the opportunity to like
check out what's going on in adult
romance
where I was like damn these chicks got
some [__] fatty
I took the opportunity to like
a little bit see what's up see what
Daniel still had to say oh wow yeah and
it was like I'm reading it like I'm
reading it like like because I had no
access to sex anything right yeah so I'm
reading it like holy [__] [__] her
nipples were Diamond hard and I'm like
diamond hard nibbles
and then and then it's like it's like
yeah I'm like like her Peach was so wet
and [__] and I'm just like oh my God
it's all euphemisms yeah yeah exactly
but then I was like this is basically
like the [__] hottest thing I've ever
seen in my whole life right man I look
up to my right
and I see my mother oh [__] down there
you're standing there with a boner just
no like I got the book right here and
then I gotta see my mom and I'm like
and I [__] and I and I [__] shove it
into the back of the you know how like
there's a bookshelf right but then
there's behind the bookshelf I shove it
behind the bookshelf and my mom was like
what the [__] is going on she walks all
the way over I don't even think she
knows what I had in my hand but she knew
that you were like yeah
my son doesn't read and then she reaches
in there and then I'm like I [__]
hate you you're a [__] I [__] hate
you I'm not like immediately I'm just
like personal attacks yeah preemptive
personal attacks like maybe like if I
bomb the ship it'll sink
oh my God
she's probably like what the [__]
where'd this come from you're [__]
cut that's why that is a [__] you except
for every month I bet you you don't have
Diamond nipples exactly oh my God but
then but then when I knew she did
because I saw her naked one time
okay okay but
so actually one of my darkest thoughts
is I've maybe prevented myself from
having another brother or sister because
I walked in on my parents
that that I think about quite a bit but
okay so so then my mom picks it up and
she's like what Stephen what the [__]
are you doing what the [__] is this
right right and then and then I
basically had
like two and a half to three hours to
figure out what the [__] I was gonna say
before my dad got home oh no because
once my dad gets home I gotta explain
what the [__] going on so I'm like I'm
like like in my room and I'm like what
the [__] am I gonna do right I'm mapping
it all out yeah yeah I was just like I
don't know what I'm gonna do you need to
pack your bags to get the [__] out of
the house I was like okay we're going
down we're going down but maybe not
today [__] right maybe not today
so what I did was I concocted
this the story about how kids at my
school were making fun of me it was
rooted in truth
okay because two grades prior to that I
didn't know what sex was but then like I
had a cool guy move into my neighborhood
and he like just told me
but so I was just like no kids will tell
me what sex is so I'm just trying to
find out because you're such a failure
as a [__] man
it's good the [__] animal and I got
her Waterworks going and [__] and she's
crying [__] and I was like it's okay I
forgive you [__] forgive you and [__]
I Gaslight my mom now I know what that
means is a car ride home or whatever
like yeah that was that was in the car
right now you're just like I don't know
what sex is I was just spitballing just
trying to [__] lipstick this is
because of you Mom and that hit my mom's
emotional cord and then I was like all
right this [__] working let's let's keep
hitting it and then we'll keep that and
we'll continue and that worked enough
where my mom didn't tell my dad
to spare you despair well no just
because to spare maybe like because he
might get mad at her huh you know what I
mean and so but both my parents were
weird about sex stuff anyway so I was
like kind of hitting on a real nerve
like but we're not ready to have the
time I was like 11 years old
really that's super smart writing career
began dude honestly was that that's when
he went back and then he got more Daniel
Steel books
and your mom doesn't know until this day
so just I never told her for Christmas
is Mommy gets him a bunch of Daniel
still books all of his first draft
scripts are all like horny [__] well
dude how do you tell your parent how do
you tell your parents like hey I
actually knew what sex was I was just
[__] around like just trying to save
my own ass yeah
I was like I can't I mean I could tell
my mom anything now I'm like hey you
know before yeah I was the ones playing
next to you to the whole school and then
I peed I used warm water because I
didn't want it to be like what the [__]
is this cold ass piss you know I was
like
I don't know I do remember though I do
remember because I I watched so many
movies I was like I am going down but
not today
nice you're a young Sean Connery a
little bit but at the same time though
like when you're that age and like
you're thinking about sex and you're
reading it and having your parents talk
to you about that stuff is the worst
thing you could ever go through well
especially because my parents like when
we were watching the Superman
with like Dean Kane yeah yeah yeah and
like him and Lois start [__] and then
I basically don't get to watch the show
anymore like Terry Hatcher yeah Terry
and so like my parents were that weird
where it's like yeah that's it yeah yeah
if that happens it's like no no bedtime
and I'm like what the [__] Superman just
started you know like that kind of [__]
oh [__] so then it was like you know my
parents would um they would they would
um embarrass me like if there's a scene
and then like there's kissing and [__]
they'll be like and then they'll and
I'll be like oh that's a girl and
they're like you're gonna want that one
day and [__] and then like every time
there's like a sex scene they'll be like
you know what they're doing and then I'm
all like what and then they're like
making a baby but my mom didn't tell me
what a [__] was so she'll be like that
baby's gonna come out of that butt later
so the whole time I grew up thinking
like
kid like you you make out in the bed and
you're gonna [__] a baby out it's weird
that your parents being so sex positive
didn't have any effect on you I know
right that is weird
dude growing up anytime there was like a
sex scene on the movie I would like just
pretend I would have to go to the
bathroom and I would just leave and walk
away and then are you beating it in
there yeah cause you don't want to see
you don't want to see that around your
parents or something so I would just
pretend like I'm like oh I have to go
pee my mom made it awkward yeah like a
sexy I'm like oh who wants orange soda
it's so weird yeah you're drinking
crushing you're getting boners
Association for life now [__] I yeah I
got embarrassed I got I got I was like I
don't want to watch it with you yeah
that's the worst and my mom's like whoa
you want that huh you want to get kissed
by a girl I couldn't watch wild things
with my mom or my dad dude you can watch
wild things at all the cover yeah I was
like man mom dad movie night you guys
want to watch Wild Things Wild Things
Are like 2001. that's when I fell in
love with Denise Richards forever
everybody did dude oh dude yeah I like
wolves not enough too oh that's the
first time I saw her yeah she was a
nuclear physicist yeah oh yeah was she
like Christmas her name was Christmas
Christmas Jones but she didn't know how
to say nuclear basically it was like
George W [__] nuke killer
she said it like that didn't they have
sex at one point and and someone sets up
like the line I got you you ready
because I thought Christmas only comes
once a year
come on let's go get out of here yeah
that's great and then she's just like I
rolling
a very good actress huh no yeah he kind
of yeah the staying power was weak yeah
the the one thing I liked about that
that wasn't really so this is bad
because it costs more money but um you
know when you did any guys have braces
yeah yeah you don't have to wear rubber
bands yeah so um the the orthodontist
was like really adamant about like he
has to wear the rubber bands or else the
bite is not gonna form correctly blah
blah blah and I was like all right cool
cool so my mom and dad would always be
like make sure you wear and make sure
you wear them and I would just never
wear them and I would lie that I was
wearing them I was supposed to have
braces for two years I ended up having
them for almost five oh [__] you didn't
wear your rubber bands yeah because I
didn't wear my rubber bands or my bite
plate or any of the extra stuff your
parents were like this dentist is cheap
laughs
so like I didn't get my my braces off
until like end of senior year but I got
them like beginning of eighth grade oh
my [__] and my parents are always like
what is going
and they would try to consult with the
orthodontist and the guy was like he
gets paid more if I have it on longer so
he was like I don't know like we're
trying everything we can Ryan are you
wearing your uh your rubber bands I'm
like yeah I don't know what's going on
man I got weird gums maybe like I was
like trying to help him structure my
mouth or something I just hated wearing
the bands and then it would be sore yeah
and then again as a kid you try to help
out and be a freaking sleuth with
everybody like let's let's let's put her
head figure out what's going on let's
get down to the business okay maybe I'm
eating too much calcium you know yeah
but then my my teeth were moving so slow
because of that and they they couldn't
figure out they're like you're wearing
your bands you're wearing your bite
plate there's no reason why this is
happening I guess I eat jawbreakers
every Monday I just cut those out but
yeah try that we'll try that it almost
it pretty much doubled an amount of time
that's a long time eight you're still
senior I mean
five years yeah five five is pretty
freaking long man senior my whole high
school life yeah
dude you're trying to think about times
where I've lied to my mom and she
actually believed me is like I can't
think I'm pretty good at knowing like oh
dude my whole because it would be my all
my sisters they would all [__] they
all knew when I was lying I was so bad
at lying so and they would just [__]
catch me in a heartbeat but I think
there was one time where I think it was
like fourth grade
and I remember and this is my friend at
the time his name was varus he was this
little white dude he was from Latvia
yeah his family was from Game of Thrones
name from Skyrim dude kind of kind of
and they were from Latvia 100
and he was like a super goodie like
nerdy like goody two shoes really smart
kid yeah and he just like told his mom
that like um he learned that he learned
curse words for me and he was like
talking about like saying [__] [__]
at home or something and then his mom
came up to my mom and was like your son
is a bad influence on my son he's
teaching him all these curse words blah
blah this blah blah that and she got
like really mad
about my mom and then my mom started
yelling at me it was like
you've been you would curse you'd be
cursing at the at the playground all the
time and like growing up my mom and my
dad have the worst mouths ever like
every word out of their mouth is like
[__] my dad's favorite phrase
was like you little [__] you little
piece of [__]
that was like his [__] place
yeah look what you did you little jerk
yeah yeah no but my dad's favorite
phrase was like calling people pieces of
[__] like this guy's a piece of [__]
yeah yeah so we just say it now because
it makes us laugh you know but like I
really don't remember cursing that much
around him but I would curse a lot
because I thought it was it was funny
yeah but my mom was like and I remember
we're driving home in the Ford Windstar
van she's like yelling at me I'm all the
way in the back seat and I'm she's
yelling at me through the [__] Ruby
man and she's like so so you're telling
me you're cursing you're cursing and I'm
like no Mom I swear like I don't curse I
don't I don't I don't even know those
words like I just did that because it's
just Yaris he's a blacksmith
he doesn't speak English I don't even
know so I I convinced her that like I
wasn't cursing like and I was like no ma
like I wasn't
and then she actually believed me and
then like this I have no idea what
happened here like a year later in fifth
grade there was this girl named Emily
and like I was like nice to her I
wouldn't have any problems with her but
she told her mom that I called her a
[__] [__] or something and I was
like dude I would never call her that
what's up with all these kids blaming
you I I never called I never had beef
with Emily like to this day I thought we
were cool and then after that yeah she
like told my mom that I was calling her
a [__] [__] or something and I was
like I never called her that like that I
know I did not do I did not do that and
then my mom is like you're over your
cursing at school calling people [__]
[__] like did you call her [__] I was
like no I didn't call her [__] [__]
but like so back to back years my mom
thinks I was like cursing all the time
but she actually believed me and was
like okay I believe you you didn't call
her a [__] [__] and you're not
cursing and I got away with that [__] so
that one you'd really do you didn't do
it I personally the first one I was
personally I was like fourth grade just
cursing the star because I thought it
was funny like it would make my friends
laugh frame you I don't know bro I
really I that's one of the things like I
think about that at least like every
quarter flirting I don't know I don't
know bro I have no idea well maybe it
was kind of like when I was a kid and I
blamed seven other people and maybe
three of them probably who didn't even
brought them in down I brought them all
down with me
laughs